alors ici parce que je suis jeune et que
je fais de la politique mais ça avait
vraiment mal commencé pour moi je
détiens le record de l'histoire de
l'éducation nationale du nombre d'
élections de délégués perdu du ce1 à la
terminale je me suis présenté onze fois
et 11 fois de suite j'ai perdu mais on
reviendra sur comment je suis arrivé ici
un peu plus tard parce que ce qui
m'intéresse maintenant ce sont les
jeunes qui ne s'intéressent pas à la
politique
et malheureusement ils sont trop
nombreux
le taux d'abstention chez les 18 25 ans
est de 66% en moyenne sur trois jeunes
il y en a deux qui votent pas et sur
certains aspects je les comprends que
personne ne les représente vraiment il
n'y a pas d'âge pour commencer à faire
de la politique ça c'est bien j'en suis
la preuve
mais le problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'âge pour arrêter aujourd'hui l'âge
moyen des parlementaires et de 65 ans
cela veut dire que toutes les décisions
qu'ils prennent toutes les lois qu'ils
votent tous les projets qu'ils défendent
eh ben ils mangeront le pissenlits par
la racine avant d'en avoir vu toutes les
conséquences et d'ailleurs ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il en soit un
minimum conscient étant donnée la
béchamel dans laquelle il nous laisse
merci pour les 98 % de dette
merci pour les deux degrés en plus d'ici
2100 merci pour les 5 millions de
chômeurs et je m'arrêtais là parce que
la liste est longue
l'économie l'environnement l'éducation
sont des problématiques les impératifs
de traiter dans une perspective de long
terme les décisions que nous prenons
aujourd'hui elles auront des
conséquences dans 20 d'entre ans dans 50
ans et donc qui mieux que les jeunes
sont légitimes pour prendre ses
décisions
on entend beaucoup dire que les jeunes
ne s'intéressent plus à la politique
peut-être mais c'est avant tout parce
que la politique ne s'intéressent plus
aux jeunes et oui pourquoi y at-il un
ministère de la jeunesse et des sports
pourquoi pas un ministère de la jeunesse
et de l'économie ou de la jeunesse et de
la défense se sont pourtant nous les
futurs créateurs d'entreprise les
agriculteurs les militaires de demain
jamais une génération n'a été aussi
informés sollicité demandeuses
d'engagement que la nôtre pourtant les
jeunes en politique aujourd'hui nous
sont souvent qu'un alibi
alors on en prend un con mais sur la
liste du maire sortant position non
éligible pour faire bonne conscience
pour faire bonne figure se donner bonne
conscience essaie de grapiller quelques
voix
et ça ce n'était plus possible
je me suis donc présenter pour les
élections municipales à saint cloud en
2014 avec 35 amis et amis d'amis vous
allez tous moins de 25 ans et vous les
deux tous les horizons politiques de la
gauche à la droite en passant par les
écolos et le centre nous avions tous des
parcours différents il y avait là des
futurs médecins des futurs avocats mais
aussi une photographe un informaticien
cuisinier et plus globalement des jeunes
qui s'en taper le coquillard de la
politique qui n'aurait jamais mis les
pieds dans un isoloir et qui d'un coup
sont devenus candidats ensemble chacun
apportant sa pierre à l'édifice nous
avons construit notre projet d'abord le
nom à nos enfants pour la fougue le clin
d'oeil à la marseillaise un peu
d'autodérision une piqûre de rappel au
front national qui n'a pas le monopole
des symboles de la nation
puis le programme axé sur les nouvelles
technologies le développement durable la
culture et bien sûr la jeunesse de nos
portions l'espoir de réveiller cette
ville après deux mois de campagne
intense
sur le terrain et sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi bien en arpentant tous les
marchés de la ville qu'à grand renfort
de twitter et de réunions publiques en
live stream nous sommes parvenus à
obtenir 15 4% des voix des deux sièges
au conseil municipal
et cerise sur le gâteau la montée
historique de la participation
éjecté le front national de ce même
conseil
la belle affaire on savait qu'avec
seulement deux élus et en plus dans
l'opposition
notre marge de manoeuvre allait être
limité
c'est le jeu mais je peux vous garantir
d'une chose jamais la ville de saint
cloud n'a été aussi dynamique et le
maire et son équipe ont commencé à
reprendre point par point notre
programme sans jamais bien sûr que nous
y soyons associés
mais c'est pas grave je fais de la
politique pour qu'on reprenne mes idées
mais du coup on s'est quand même mis à
rêver de quelque chose d'encore plus
grand et avec les plus motivés on a
décidé de lancer un mouvement national
qui a vu le jour il ya maintenant deux
mois
allons enfants le parti de la jeunesse
je préfère être clair tout de suite la
galère que représente la création d'un
parti politique dépasse toutes les lois
même la loi de murphy la loi sur la mère
de mon maximum mais on avait à coeur de
montrer que ce qui s'était passé à saint
cloud c'était pâques du buzz pas qu'un
coup de com que le projet comportait que
l'idéal qu'on défend des pouvait
s'appliquer partout et s'adressait à
tous des règles du jeu elle était même
que des jeunes de tous les horizons
politiques de tous les milieux
avec cette fois ci le challenge
supplémentaire de saint porter partout
en france
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus d'une
soixantaine à s'occuper du parti au
quotidien avec plus d'une centaine
d'ambassadeurs qui relaie notre message
sur l'ensemble du territoire et bientôt
500 adhérents et nous allons continuer à
grossir pour atteindre en 2020 notre
objectif mettre dix mille jeunes dans
les conseils municipaux de france
le choix de la ville comme objectif
électoral est extrêmement important tout
d'abord parce que c'est à cette échelle
que la présence d'un de trois jeunes
peut réellement avoir un impact peut
réellement faire la différence et on l'a
vu à saint cloud mais c'est aussi parce
que c'est à cette échelle que le clivage
gauche droite est le plus insignifiant
j'en ai même contre-productif les
parties n'ont rien à faire dans les
mairies oui que vous soyez un maire les
républicains de la roque d'anthéron ou à
maire socialiste de la préfecture du
gers vous êtes confrontés au même
problème est pire encore aux mêmes
solutions il n'y a pas deux cents
manière de gérer le tri sélectif
l'éclairage de noël l'éclosion de start
up
j'aime d'ailleurs rappelé que la
séparation entre la gauche et la droite
de 1792 à une époque où il fallait que
s'exprimer pour ou contre la mort du roi
alors je suis quelqu'un arrive à trouver
le rapport entre eux
la décapitation de louis saez d'une part
et vous ordures ménagères de l'autre je
suis preneur il n'y a pas que sur le
clivage partisan que notre système
politique est obsolète
prenons l'exemple des départements leur
délimitation actuelle date de napoléon
qui avait réalisé ce découpage sur un
unique critère la possibilité de
traverser un département en une journée
de cheval mesdames messieurs
l'organisation territoriale de la france
repose sur les performances d'un
canasson il ya 200 ans
alors à un moment on nous parle de la
dette de la multiplication des strates
administratives
je trouve que notre millefeuille
territorial à un arrière-goût de crottin
mais c'est dans l'exercice de la
démocratie
que le fossé entre nos institutions
vieillissante et la réalité
contemporaine de nos sociétés et le plus
marquant sur ce point là la politique à
une révolution de retard aujourd'hui un
parti un homme propose un programme
contentant de voter pour ou contre mais
la révolution digitale transforme en
profondeur notre société elle offre la
possibilité à chacun de s'exprimer
librement
de manière immédiate surtout les et sur
tous les sujets possibles ce que allons
z'enfants propose pour reprendre un
terme un peu à la mode en ce moment
c'est du brise et la politique de
renverser la pyramide est ainsi ça
serait à nous les citoyens de proposer
nos idées et aux candidats de choisir
pour lesquelles il souhaite se battre et
nous représenter mais le plus
merveilleux c'est que la révolution
digitale est aussi une formidable
opportunité pour les élus elle leur
offre la possibilité d'avoir un panel
gigantesque d'idées nouvelles
on y reviendra juste après mais aussi
par exemple de mieux communiquer avec
leurs administrés et avec les outils de
big data de mieux cerner leurs problèmes
les bien sûr de mieux répondre
la politique c'est faire vivre ensemble
des gens différents
c'est votre quotidien c'est votre vie
c'est votre ville et dans cette optique
là le plus grand s'il tente de france
c'est vous tous là des idées je vous le
promets et d'ailleurs on va essayer
ensemble quelque chose d'aller tous
fermé les yeux juste trente secondes
allez-y fermer les yeux n'ai pas peur
vous allez vous imaginez dans votre
ville et est-ce qu'il n'ya pas quelque
chose que vous souhaiteriez améliorée
que vous souhaiteriez changer quelque
chose que vous souhaiteriez voir
apparaître ou disparaître
elle hésitait
monde parfait je suis sûr que 90%
d'entre vous ont trouvé au moins une
piste d'amélioration et c'est là tout
mon poids
imaginez vous avez réfléchi cela que 30
secondes mais je suis persuadé que tout
le monde que d'avoir ou a déjà des idées
pour sa région pour la france et même
l'europe et c'est dans cette perspective
qu alan enfants a mis en place la ruche
une plate forme de démocratie
participative où chacun est libre de
proposer ses idées des mets de partage
et de commenter celle des autres quand
on sait que sur internet la vidéo d'un
panda qui éternue peut faire 200
millions de vues imaginez la puissance
le retentissement les conséquences que
peuvent avoir une bonne idée
le fait d'être jeune nous permet d'avoir
une bonne compréhension du monde qui
nous entoure à nos enfants est un parti
mais c'est aussi une start up où l'on se
bat plus pour les idées que pour le
pouvoir
il n'y a pas de rapports hiérarchiques
bref on est cool et je pense que c'est
important pour renouer ce lien perdu et
tous ensemble réenchanter la politique
oui tous ensemble parce que si l enfant
est piloté par les jeunes il s'adresse à
tous ce sont notre manière de
fonctionner nos idées notre vision de la
france et de la politique qui devrait
ces jeunes pas notre électorat
c'est pour ça que garder une idée pour
soi c'est égoïste et inconscient c'est
pour ça qu'il est indispensable que les
jeunes jouent d'un rôle en politique
c'est pour ça qu'il est nécessaire de
changer la politique et de la confronter
aux évolutions de la société
ferez le pari de la jeunesse en prenant
son parti merci beaucoup